let's look at this example okay four
steps right
let's start with the data what do we
know um this is the now we're on to the
normals question okay
so x squared is equal to four y
which tells you what
so now from that i can write out what my
coordinates for p
and q are right p p and q
r um p is at two a p a p squared
being that that's the value of a i've
got this
yeah good same for q
okay what other data do i have
good so i've got this coordinate zero
minus two
p q passes through zero minus two
okay now i don't think anyone had
troubles here and we've already shown
how to
prove the equation of chord use two
point four
okay so where you should land up is what
do you conclude after you get that
equation and you sum this in what do you
get
really simple equation good
you get this okay so this corresponds to
this guy
right which we sub it all the time in
order to simplify out or try and get rid
of one parameter and so on
okay great that's the data now what was
the next step
parametric equations right okay now
now i'm not going to take any more
shortcuts it's the um
point of intersection between the
normals okay
so just like before we found the
equations of the tangents
and then we solve simultaneously let's
do it for the normals okay so i'll put
in all my lines of working just so you
can know
that you're on the right track but it
should start off by saying
well what's the normal at peak so
okay just like the tangent i know the
point it passes through and i know it's
gradient
so i'll use the same form
okay coordinates are fairly
straightforward y
minus p squared um
these x the x coordinate is also simple
minus 2p
now be careful because i've seen a few
of you forget this
the gradient we want to be perpendicular
to
the tangent right so opp it'll be
minus one on p okay you've got to get
the reciprocal you've got to make sure
it's negative
okay all right now we can tidy this up a
little bit right
i can't uh that's minus
minus x on p what's that going to be
that's just yeah plus plus two right
double negative
and there's a p squared over here okay
that looks terrible
but that's as simple as it gets okay
likewise
at q
minus x on that parameter
and that parameter squared okay
so now what where am i actually
okay so i want to find the point of
intersection okay now
again this is just a bit of algebra work
okay so
where do you get up to when you solve
for x what x-coordinate do you get
do you want me to do the working to show
you yes please should i do the work
once you end up there actually you know
i will do the working
because a few of you a few of you have
come through with questions about like
how did i get this wrong okay
so let's let's go ahead it's these two
lines here
right so what am i going to get on each
side
if i have minus 1 over p
2 p squared and the same thing over here
okay the twos cancel and
at the same time i'm also going to
rearrange get my squares together
and get these fractions together okay i
think that will be making it easier to
put together
right so let's get the squares on this
side
cancel that cancel that take the q
squared over in the same way i'm going
to add
whoops missing an x add this minus 1
over p x
onto this side okay yeah did you know uh
that thing
where you've got two p q's q where'd you
get that
that's the previous question sorry
though the the um analog to that
like that relationship between p and q
is this where did i get it from
i found the equation the chord and i
subbed in this point because the chord
has to pass through it
okay so that's how you get like that
kind of relationship right
okay is that okay so far
all right now what was i after this is
i'm getting towards a parametric
equation for x
so i can factorize it over here some of
you got to this point
and you're like i've clearly done
something wrong because this
looks terrible okay you haven't done
anything wrong
it does look terrible but you gotta stay
with it okay so
how would you go about this um because
you've got these fractions here
right in order to get them to interact
with these you just got to put them
together
right you just got to add them up so if
i have x over here what am i going to
have
this is going to be q minus p on
p cubed is that right
and this is p minus q p plus
q right
yes okay so what i'm going to do here is
this p minus q and this q minus p are
almost the same what's the difference
minus one so to cancel them i'm going to
have to put a minus sign somewhere
it doesn't matter which side it's on
okay but i'm going to put it over there
because i want the x on its own
lastly to isolate the x what have i got
to do
this is 1 over p q so just multiply
through by p q
so this is what i have okay but as some
of you have noticed i've already worked
out what pq is
right
okay so done come here
okay right
is everyone satisfied so far is that
okay
i will shortly but not yet i'm done
that's a
that is a parametric equation for x okay
how do i get a parametric equation for y
okay so yes
i feel like i'm missing a page
um
i'm trying to get back and working
because i think i put my page in the
wrong order and there's a simple way to
do it
it's terrible
okay so what's my equation for y is this
okay is that right yes that's that's
this yes that's one of the equations of
the normals
doesn't matter which one okay now what
interests me is
um i'm going to substitute x into this
in a second
right but i have a couple of different
ways to write
x and even though this is simpler
it might not be the best one to use to
put in this equation can anyone see why
exactly right so this previous line okay
actually is more helpful to me because i
have to divide x by p
right so i might as well take some form
of x that's got an extra p
in it because we'll just get rid of it
okay does that make sense okay
so i'm going to substitute x into this
line from
this second last line here this one okay
so minus 1 over p times that
minus one over p is going to get rid of
the minus p on
the front so i'm going to end up with
this
okay is that all right and what have i
got here
i've got a p q q squared
2 and a p squared i already know what p
q is
right so p squared plus q squared
plus 40. okay happy
so now i have parametric equation for x
tick parametric equation for y tick how
do i put them together
this is a standard we've done this one a
few times
i'm going to square x right okay so
let's take this equation
uh what should i call it i haven't
numbered any of these queries i'm just
going to call it one for now
if i take equation one it'll probably be
easiest to square if i divide
through first okay so i'm going to
divide through by minus a half
okay is that all right that'll give me
p plus q on the other side and now i'll
square
squared square okay
because it's squared don't worry about
the negative right so
x squared on four right
p squared plus q squared plus 2 p
q all right now hold on a second
i know what all these pieces are right p
squared plus
q squared look back a couple lines
that's y minus four isn't it y minus
four
see that yes no it's totally at me or
have i totally lost you
can we can change two into four yeah we
totally care
okay so i've got next squared on four
that all cancels out so i've got this
so now i land yeah here now
look that's what you do
why are you doing this to me you know
okay now stop all right let's pause
in case you're not tracking with us
right
where we've landed is back where we
started
this is the equation of the original
parabola
okay now stop assuming you trust me
or your own working and that this is
right okay
what does that mean the answer the
question what's the question telling us
if you take these particular normals
okay
right what do they pass through that
chords through zero minus two
okay so i'm picking a particular pair of
normals right
what that means is when you look at
where they intersect
where they intersect is
back on the parabola you know something
like i mean this is not perfectly
accurate but something like this
well yeah you get the idea right angle
okay and of course i can move them
around and as i move them they keep on
intersecting on the parabola
okay yeah
is that the y coordinate
the y coordinate is up here
all right now